foreign
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsey show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
amazing relationships I'm Ramsey
personality George Campbell flying solo
today that's right America they left me
at the helm there's no one to stop me
from making poor choices and so it could
be an interesting show could be my last
one it's up to you let's make it a good
one the number to call is triple eight
eight two five five two two five that's
triple eight eight two five five two two
five you jump in we'll talk about your
life and your money whatever's going on
I'm happy to be a sounding board and
maybe give you some advice but remember
it's worth what you paid for it let's
kick it off with clay in Perry Georgia
Clay what's going on
hey what's going on thanks for taking my
call absolutely how can I help
uh yes I am a little nervous
it's just me clay there's no one even to
be scared of I'm the least intimidating
person you could meet
uh yes I am I'm 20 years old and I was
wondering I want to move on my parents
house eventually but I don't know how
much money I need or how to do that
where do you want to go and why
uh just move out just uh start like my
adult life whatever just try to
experience that okay cool so are you
moving out of the state where do you
plan on going
uh I'm honestly just like 20 minutes
away from my parents house so okay and
is this an apartment where are you going
exactly uh apartment yeah okay and will
you be living alone or with roommates
uh probably alone most likely okay and
you know exactly how much that
apartment's gonna cost
uh around 12 1300
and have you looked into any other fees
like initial deposits that may be
involved
I do not know
um I'm currently out of it and I was 36
months saved up so oh awesome at 20
years old and you're currently working I
assume yeah yep okay did you go to
college or you just went straight to the
workforce uh just straight to the
workforce I'm actually going to school
in August to
uh do electrical um like the electrician
that is awesome big fan of the trades
and what are you doing right now for
work
uh I build storage barns portable
storage barns that sounds fun what are
you making doing that
uh around last year made 91 uh so about
initially probably 90 so 100 a hundred
grand at 20 years old with no four-year
degree
yep I hope everyone in America is
listening to this going oh my gosh maybe
I shouldn't send my kid to school for a
random degree they don't need that cost
300 000 clay you're amazing
I appreciate it so you make great money
and this rent the key we want to look
for when it comes to rent is that it's
about a quarter of your take-home pay so
the question becomes do you make 4 800
bucks a month
yes about five or five or six take home
perfect and as long as you have the
initial deposit I don't want you
touching the emergency fund if you don't
have to for this because truly it's not
an emergency so you want to make sure
you have that money ready to go so I
would call up that apartment complex and
say hey what are all of the the fees
involved with me getting into this
apartment
I got you and then do you have furniture
I do not that's yeah well that's one of
the things I didn't know how much you
saved up for to move out or something
like that for furniture and stuff like
that well you can do it real cheaply and
what I did was just go on Facebook
Marketplace and you know friends are
always giving away stuff family Facebook
groups in your neighborhood there's even
Facebook groups that are just called buy
nothing Facebook groups where they just
give away stuff
okay so I would go cheap until you need
to upgrade but really you're out of debt
with an emergency fund if you want to
buy some decent Furniture online on you
know like a Wayfair or something and
really start to kick off your adult life
go for it as long as you budget for it
awesome sounds good also I have one more
question sure
uh I have a about like a 40 000 truck
paid off I didn't know is that worth
keeping because gas mileage on is pretty
bad and just like downgrading some or
what do you think
well it's less than half of your annual
income and so as far as the the rules
that we set for owning things with
wheels and Motors you're not above that
but if you don't need the truck and you
can sell that thing for 40 Grand and
downgrade to something that has better
fuel economy I would do it
okay but do you need the truck for work
uh no I just just like it it's big big
bike you are a very impressive sir most
guys that don't even build storage barns
say they need a truck for hauling some
mulch from Lowe's twice a year
yeah the fact that you have this level
of self-awareness is inspiring
I appreciate it absolutely man and I'll
tell you clay I moved out of my parents
home at 20 years old and I moved across
the country from Boston to Mobile
Alabama and uh you know it can be scary
because for the first time you're like
it's on me and I gotta start paying my
own bills and for the cell phone and the
insurance but it's also it gives you so
much dignity and I'm telling you no one
understands it until you leave the house
that yes it's scary but there's
something about not being tethered and I
love my parents there was nothing that
wasn't animosity that caused me to move
I just knew it was time
and I wanted to step out like you are
and so uh Dave always says an eagle that
doesn't leave the nest is a turkey and
so I'm proud of you man being debt free
having a killer job doing this the right
way so set a budget I'm gonna go ahead
and gift you every dollar so hang on the
line Austin's gonna pick up that's our
budgeting app that I personally use and
it's so helpful when you step out into
your adult life you're making money and
you want to give every single dollar an
assignment income minus expenses equals
zero
and this is huge for anyone out there
who's going all right I'm either out of
school or I'm in the workforce and I'm
young and I'm just gonna stay at home
until you know my I'll get my life
together until I get my finances in
order
listen if you have an exit strategy
that's fine if you're going hey Mom and
Dad give me one year I'm going to get
out of this student loan debt I'm going
to get out of this credit card debt I'm
going to pay off this car and then I'm
on my way out
but I'm personally not a fan of just
living with family to live with family
because you can save some money there is
something that gets you out of bed in
the morning when you have to pay a bill
and you have to go to work and you got
to kill something and drag it home that
gives you a little pep in your step
and I'm not here to knock on any
generation or anyone's personal living
situation
and I know culturally this is a hard
thing a lot of non-american cultures you
just kind of live with family forever
and you take care of each other and this
kind of this cycle that happens but man
there is such freedom in going it's on
me now it's on the guy in the mirror I
can't rely on Mommy to cook my meals and
gosh I wish I still could because my mom
is one of the best cooks in the world
but it's on me to figure that out and
that's a such a huge part of mature
maturing and growing as a person and I
think we should all aspire to grow in
all areas of our life but especially
when it comes to taking care of
ourselves and taking care of our
families I think the people that are
still at home at 34 they're gonna have a
hard time meeting someone
and getting married and starting their
own family and changing their family
tree if they're kind of stuck and
tethered and so I kind of like the fear
that comes along with getting out of the
house and having to figure that out so
if that's you I encourage you to make
plans to do that have the exit strategy
have the tough conversation with mom or
dad go increase the income go pay off
the debt so that you can start your own
life
because we need less adults who are
acting like children and Clay is such a
great example of what it looks like to
do this the right way so I'm inspired by
you man enjoy that every dollar app and
good luck with the move check out our
friends at PODS moving and storage as
you go through that process they'll take
real real good care of you hey more of
your calls coming up America the number
is triple eight eight two five five two
two five this is a show about you we'll
be right back
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
we've been doing business at Ramsey for
more than 30 years by now we're a
well-oiled machine but it wasn't always
that way yes we've always had a vision
always had determination and a drive to
help people but what we didn't have was
one central place to access all our
numbers so that we could get further
ahead or quickly see when we needed to
Pivot we were always jumping back and
forth between different systems and
spreadsheets so when netsuite by Oracle
helped us Wrangle our Revenue inventory
expenses and more into one place it was
a game changer and netsuite's number one
Cloud Financial system can help your
business gain the same visibility
because businesses thrive on timely data
and next week's real-time analytics can
help your business have immediate access
to your numbers daily so you always know
where you stand and you can move quickly
so go to netsuite.com Ramsey today and
set up a free product tour that's
netsuite.com Ramsey
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsay show I'm
George camel host of The George Campbell
YouTube channel co-host of smart money
happy hour and your solo host today on
the Ramsay show it's good to be with you
give me a call at triple eight eight two
five five two two five if you want to
talk about your life and your money if
you've got that burning question you've
been thinking about and you're like I
could Google it but I don't know what's
Google's gonna give me and I could ask
my broke brother-in-law but I know what
he's going to say I'll try to be as
honest as I can without hurting feelings
which I've been known to do not my
intention it's just a byproduct when you
tell people the truth well hey if you
missed it we had a great event called
America's labor crisis and that live
stream is going to be broadcast on TBN
on Friday May 19th starting at 8 pm
Central to uh 8 P.M eastern time sorry
it's 7 PM Central Time
and if you're wondering what this is all
about well Dave Ramsey and Mike Rowe are
teaming up with five best-selling
authors and experts to discuss the state
of work in America today you don't want
to miss this again that's on TBN Friday
May 19th starting at 8 pm Eastern Time
all right let's get to the phones George
joins us in Chicago George it is good to
talk to another George
hey George thanks for taking my call um
so just a really quick question uh my
wife and I
um we're getting ready for the summer
because my wife uh being a school
teacher
um it's not an option for her to get
paid during the summer months so
basically she won't get paid for the
next like three months
um and since we're on baby step number
two my question really is
um so I I feel like we have enough
savings to get us through uh from July
to September
um should we stop doing the the snowball
the debt snowball
um and and just get through these three
months or do you think we'll be we'll be
okay to to keep uh paying off the the
debts with the increasing
um with the rollover right from from the
prior debts that we've been able to pay
off great question so the only time I
would recommend someone pause baby step
two or pause the baby steps in general
is what we would call storm or stork
mode stork mode of course you're having
a baby let's pause and save up cash and
just pile it up until mom and baby are
home and healthy and storm mode is hey
there was an emergency we didn't know
was coming there was a medical thing
there was a job loss but with your
situation we knew this was coming we
knew summer happens we know teachers
aren't in school during the Summers and
so I would if I were you go hey what
could she do over the summer to bring an
income now you said it's not an option
what do you mean by that
so it it used to so Chicago Public
Schools they used to allow you to to to
get paid they would pay your salary
throughout the 12 months okay but they
stopped at like six or seven years ago
so yeah but it's not illegal for her to
earn income in other ways during the
summer
right no it's not and then and then the
other so usually and I guess I should
have specified towards so usually she
does Work summer
um summer school okay um but this year
this year she opted out just because
she's going to be taking a surgery
um and I was like well this would be the
best time to do it right because that
way you don't have to take your vacation
time or anything like that got it so
she'll probably not be able to work for
like a month okay so aside from that
surgery and her healing up and getting
better I would be looking at ways you
can increase income and she can create
income during that time and obviously
there's ways she can do that as a
teacher uh through private tutoring uh
maybe teaching ESL or VIP kit or go go
kit or one of those kind of online
platforms where she can use her skills
to create money but there's also a ton
of other ways that might even make her
more money things like Child Care dog
sitting dog walking doing Amazon
delivery and grocery delivery has she
looked into anything like that to create
income
um you know we we haven't looked at but
I mean those are great ideas we haven't
spoke but we'll definitely look into
that okay a great idea we've got a great
article all about side hustles that I
worked on and I'll make sure that you
get a link from our friend Austin in the
booth and I'll make sure Austin gets
that link that will help give you some
ideas but what you want to look at with
these side hustles is what is how much
time do we have what talents do we have
and then what's the target the target
you already have set you've got some
debt to pay off how much debt do you
have
um we have uh do are you asking
including the home or just just Consumer
Debt outside just your baby step too
yeah yeah
um maybe like 60 000. okay what kind of
debt is that
yeah
uh cards and and uh student loans okay
so what's your next smallest debt
what's what's the next I'm sorry what's
the next smallest and as far as balance
goes
um I want to say hold on I'll show you
right now I haven't
I don't have it in front of me I
apologize if they're a good baby step
two done they've got the list they've
got every dollar yeah I know I I have a
list awesome I don't I don't know it by
heart but yeah I have it right here okay
so the next one is
so the next one isn't really that big
it's um it's like a we opened up like a
medical credit card um and it's only
like fifteen hundred dollars which we
get we can pay we can pay off this next
month easily great how much money do you
guys have in the bank
um we have about four thousand in the
checking
um and we have about the same in uh we
have like a separate short-term savings
account so I I want to say we have about
8 000 right now okay if I'm in your
shoes other than this surgery no is
coming up I would get the details on
what that's going to cost us out of
pocket and aside from that whatever you
have allocated for your budget for next
month plus a small buffer maybe 500
bucks in checking I would love to see
the rest of that savings go towards your
debt and start to knock some of this out
even before the surgery begins
yes sir and so I think if you do all
that you find ways to increase income
you're going to be able to pay this off
faster but I would not say hey let's
pause the baby steps because she's not
working in the summertime I want to see
this thing keep moving because you're
going to lose momentum fall is going to
come around things are going to get busy
again and all of a sudden it's not going
to become a priority in your life and
getting out of debt needs to be the
number one priority for you guys right
now so uh we'll make sure you get that
link and for those of you listening we
will drop a link into the show notes if
you're listening on podcasts and into
the YouTube description over there if
you guys want to get inspired and get
some ideas thanks for the call Joe is up
next in Dayton Ohio Joe welcome to the
Ramsay show
hey George how you doing doing great how
can I help
so um I just wanted to wonder what your
opinion of being financially ready for a
single income marriage was I wanted to
see if I met those criteria and if not
what I need to do next okay hit me with
some of your criteria what do you have
going on
um right now I'm uh I'm single I'm
looking to start dating but I don't want
to start until I know I'm ready to oh
wow this is what you're very future
thinking here there's no lady in the
life right now
well there was but she took a break to
get some more school done so I'm
thinking before I get started again I
want to make sure I'm ready so okay so
you're thinking what do I do to become
financially ready not for a couple to
get ready
right okay cool
so um so I make about 52 000 a year
that's
um Plus benefits That's not including
taxes
um I have about 15 000 saved up I have
about 40 000 in private Investments
and a twelve thousand dollar Roth IRA
how old are you I'm 21. oh my goodness
how'd you do this
um well my dad has been a big fan of
Dave Ramsey for a while so he's been a
bit of a
um yeah he's been a bit of a Dave Ramsey
honestly so you're kind of a financial
peace baby and the Apple didn't fall far
from the tree
yeah exactly you are so far ahead of
most adult Americans twice or three
times your age
oh thank you
okay to my dad so you're saying Hey how
do I get ready for marriage I mean
financially you're in a great spot you
don't have any debt
no okay
and what are the Investments for this
40K
so uh my dad has a property management
company he bought some real estate
investment properties he didn't want to
use operating funds so if you borrowed
from me I'm getting paid back at 3.5
whoa okay
well do you rent right now
uh actually I'm still living at home
that's part of my compensation oh cool
okay well my next goal for you if you've
got the emergency fund you're already
investing 15 of your income I would be
looking at getting a home eventually so
save up that down payment and so when
you do meet that special someone and
you've got a home or even a paid for
home you will be light years ahead and
on your way to Building Wealth
okay but dude thank you you were
checking all the boxes if any ladies are
listening who are in your age range
they're going how do I find a Joe out
there this guy's got it figured out he's
not trying to stay broke he's trying to
build wealth that's who I want to Hitch
my ride to so way to go Joan proud of
you man thanks for the call I'm inspired
by the young people listen they get a
bad rap out here but I'm getting calls
from 20 year olds 21 year olds who would
out school any anyone out there when it
comes to their money management so I'm
inspired during this episode today
[Music]
thank you
buying a home is one of the biggest
decisions of your life you need a
partner like Churchill Mortgage
Churchill is one of the highest rated
lenders in the country and their Ramsay
trusted because they do what's right for
you Churchill works with you to build a
mortgage the Ramsay way one that doesn't
bust your budget sets you up for
financial success and helps you get out
of debt faster go to
churchillmortgage.com today and get
started
[Music]
foreign
this is the Ramsey Show I'm George camel
your host this hour ride in Solo our
crew is uh all over the place right now
we've got Rachel Cruz Dr John deloney
and Jade warshaw down in New York City
or I guess up in New York City as the
crow flies and they were doing a fox
business panel this morning having a
good time over there I'm a little
jealous but I also get to hang out here
in this wonderful studio with some
wonderful people and a wonderful crowd
so who's jealous now Rachel
but hey we've taken a lot of calls so
far from Young Folks in their you know
early 20s 2021 and this article right
here is interesting it says almost half
of gen Z's have side jobs as money fears
take over according to Deloitte and
here's the stat 46 of Jen's ears
currently have either a full-time or
part-time job in addition to their main
one a new Deloitte survey shows and the
figure is slightly lower for Millennials
at 37 percent it goes on to say side
jobs are on the rise as folks struggle
to make ends meet some of the most
popular second jobs are selling products
and services online working gig economy
jobs like food delivery or ride hailing
artistic Outlets or creating social
media content as an influencer look at
that
it says while money is the top reason
for having a side job respondents also
see it as a way to monetize their
Hobbies unplug from their primary job
expand their networks and in some cases
develop skills for a new career path and
of course the survey shows that cost of
living is the biggest concern and it's
especially pertinent as over half of
each generation say they live paycheck
to paycheck five percent more than a
year ago
so here's what this tells me obviously
there's a sad part to this of
inflation's crazy or in debt like crazy
people are trying to make ends meet so
they're turning to these jobs for those
reasons but there's a byproduct of this
that I love that they mentioned
which is it monetizes their Hobbies it
helps them unplug from their primary job
it expands their networks and helps them
to develop skills for a new career path
and I live this out in my 20s as I sat
there with forty thousand dollars in
student loan debt and credit card debt
going oh my gosh I did everything the
system told me to do everything Society
told me to do I worked hard in school
got good grades so I could get into the
College of my dreams only to find out I
couldn't afford the College of my dreams
and then you take out student loans to
pay for it because you had to because
there's no other way and this is how you
get by and make it
and so what do you do as a 22 year old
23 year old sitting there with a pile of
debt and mommy and daddy aren't around
to help you anymore well I turned to
side jobs and of course I got my first
big boy job here at Ramsey Solutions 10
years ago which was awesome but I went
through Financial Peace University for
the first time back in 2013 and it got
me fired up to pay off this forty
thousand dollars and I wanted to do it
fast and so on top of my salary I went
what else could I be doing
and so I use my skills my marketing
know-how and I was a second shooter for
videography for weddings I was building
websites using Squarespace for small
businesses and entrepreneurs and authors
and speakers charging you know 1500
bucks a website I was driving for Uber
and Lyft on the weekends instead of
going out with my friends to make an
extra 100 bucks 200 bucks 300 bucks
I also was a Nielsen family if you know
what that is which means Nielsen who is
does all the ratings for you know TV
media radio like this show and I carry
it around a little beeper-sized device
that would listen to all the media that
I listened to and I would get paid based
on how long I had that turned on and I
cannot tell you how uncool I looked in
my khaki pants carrying around a little
beeper but it made me an extra 20 bucks
a month and it was almost no work on my
end
on top of that I was in marketing at the
time so I went I could do some marketing
Consulting and so I started doing that
for those small businesses for
entrepreneurs and helped them launch
podcasts and launch Books uh and as I
stepped into an MC and host role I went
okay I have talents on stage to be a
host in MC I can go do this for other
events and so I did that to help us save
for a down payment when it came time for
us to get a house I also was a musician
and so I would license my music online
to make some extra money that way and
you know sometimes it'd be 50 bucks for
a wedding video or a Church's video and
sometimes it would be Ford saying hey we
want to use your music on our YouTube
channel and I'd get a 1500 check for one
song that I had already recorded and so
there's a lot of creative ways to make
money out there depending on your
talents I have zero talents when it
comes to handyman work when it comes to
cooking and baking but some of y'all out
there
have amazing talent and people will pay
for those adorable smash cakes for the
one-year-old's birthday party and for
that wedding cake when they're on a
budget and can't go to the fancy Bakery
and people will pay to have light bulbs
changed out because they're too lazy
they can't do it physically because
they're older have disabilities whatever
the reason is you would be shocked at
what people are willing to pay for and
we know rich people are scared of leaves
they hire people just to blow the scary
leaves away
I pay people to watch my dog to mow my
lawn to do the electrical work that I
have no clue what I'm doing and I don't
want to sit there on a Saturday watching
YouTube videos from some guy named Larry
who's going on for 30 minutes about how
it was back in his day while trying to
teach me how to change the socket out
and so get creative with this think
about three things your time
your talent and your target
time is simple how much time do you have
to devote to these side hustles
some people it's two hours some people
it's 20 hours
some of y'all that are single out there
and you're sitting at home figuring out
who the next bachelor's gonna be and
who's going to get kicked off the island
yo there is so much work to be done out
there that you can make 20 25 30 bucks
and beyond your time and your talent
which is what you what are you good at
and let me tell you if you have a car
you are hopefully good at driving and
you can deliver packages for Amazon Flex
so you can deliver groceries with
shipped or instacart
and so beyond any having any talents or
time we all have a Target what are you
doing this for because if you're just
doing it because you're bored that's
fine but if you're doing it because you
want to get out of debt you're going to
stick to it you're going to work harder
at it you're going to work harder for
those tips and you're going to make some
good money and I'll throw a list at you
right now rattle some off because a lot
of you hear Dave say go deliver pizzas
and you're like okay I want to deliver
pizzas first of all pizza delivery can
make some great money
and here's a list number one working
overtime a lot of you have jobs you can
work overtime
people can flip Furniture you can get
that couch Facebook Marketplace that's a
little Dusty a little crusty you get
that couch for 50 bucks you clean it up
you take better photos of it and you can
re-list it
for 200 bucks like that you can flip
things that you buy at Goodwill
you can sell old clothes on Poshmark and
online you can sell stuff on Facebook
Marketplace you can dog sit
through apps like Rover you can dog walk
through an app called wag Child Care is
a huge one there is a huge shortage of
babysitters right now and babysitting
has gotten crazy expensive
I'm to I'm here parents saying oh yeah
our babysitter charges 30 bucks now an
hour 35 bucks 40 bucks an hour for two
and I'm going oh my goodness why are we
not all just babysitting constantly
house cleaning this is a huge one you
can make a hundred two hundred dollars
for sitting there for a few hours and
scrubbing a toilet because someone else
didn't want to
you can donate plasma
Josiah from our borrowed future
documentary this was a way he made
hundreds of dollars a month for his
family that helped him get out of debt
of course you can drive for Lyft and
Uber deliver food with ubereats and
doordash grocery delivery through
instacart and shipt you can teach ESL or
teach through VIP kid or go go kid
tutoring cutting grass mowing the lawn
doing the yard work pulling the weeds
power washing snow plowing
valet parking bartending on the side
focus groups research studies retail
jobs
that are now paying 15 or 20 bucks an
hour you can be a transcriptionist on
sites like rev.com where you just type
out things you're hearing for money
that's a cool way to make some extra
dough mystery shoppers
if you've got a camera and some know-how
you can do photography videography
graphic design work if you've got some
photoshop skills you can help people
move help them pack help organize you
can be a virtual assistant you can be a
financial coach we have a great program
that trains Financial coaches and some
of these Financial coaches out there
they're making amazing money helping
people follow the Ramsay plan
and you can make 150 bucks a session
doing that while making an impact
so don't tell me you can truthfully
there are so many ways in America today
to make money so you can tell me you
won't you can make all the excuses in
the world but don't tell me that you
can't make more money in America today
to keep up with inflation to get out of
debt to save the down payment to build
wealth and that's not forever it's a
season so ask yourself what am I willing
to do right now that's going to set me
up for the long term what am I willing
to do and none of the people that do
this stuff look back with the regret
their kids watch them work hard and
those kids end up working hard because
they saw mom and dad do that so whatever
that goal is look at your time and your
talent and your Target and go after it
and get creative and see what happens
this is the land of opportunity and this
is the Ramsay show
[Music]
we are back right here on the Ramsey
Show don't call it a comeback I'm George
camel your Hostess our flying solo
taking your calls at triple eight eight
two five five two two five and hey if
you're a new listener to the show first
of all welcome we are so glad you're
here we talk a whole lot of jargon on
this show like gazelle intensity and
baby step 3B and if you want to dive
deeper into what all that means what are
these Ramsay baby steps go to
ramseysolutions.com and click on the get
started button when you do that you'll
fill out a few simple questions and we
will help you figure out the next best
step for your financial Journey based on
where you're at today that's
ramseysolutions.com get started
and if you want to take it a step
further you want to dive even deeper
than that I've got a great opportunity
for you
you can go through Financial Peace
University and get the whole picture in
just nine lessons and this is the same
course that I went through when I first
started here at Ramsay Solutions 10
years ago and those nine lessons changed
my life quite literally it gave me this
Paradigm Shift where I went oh my gosh
the system is designed to keep me broke
it's designed that way that's how they
like it
and when they do that I can stay in that
cycle I can be the rat in the Maze
trying to keep up with this weird credit
score game and use my credit cards to
get the cash back because somehow that's
what's going to be the ticket to wealth
and freedom and then I realized by
watching Financial Peace University that
there's a way out that it's not all my
fault
but it is my responsibility
that I'm gonna be in control of my
financial destiny I'm not just gonna
have to hope for it
and then by the end of Financial Peace
University it showed me how I can Buck
this system completely and get Financial
Freedom on my terms and build wealth way
faster and get out of the clutches and
the grip of this toxic money culture and
so I want you to join me because I'm
going to be leading folks through that
same class that changed my life
and get this the average person who
takes Financial Peace University becomes
debt free of all their Consumer Debt in
less than two years that could be you
and this is the proven system everything
you need to know about money in one
place and the reason you'll pay off debt
faster
is not just because of the advice you
hear in the lessons it's because you
have a community of people in your
corner and for the first time in your
life maybe you're going oh my gosh I'm
not alone other people have done stupid
stuff too and other people want to get
better and other people want to learn
how to live without a credit score and
get that house of their dreams the right
way and they're going to push you
they're going to hold you accountable
and I will too we're going to encourage
you so right now we're pouring jet fuel
on the whole thing because all the
Ramsay personalities are going to
personally lead you through a class and
it's an honor to be one of those people
my class starts June 20th we're going to
meet twice a week for about four and a
half weeks going through all nine
lessons we're gonna meet at 11 30
Central Time 12 30 Eastern Time
and you do not want to miss this you
don't have to keep wandering around
trying to figure out how to do this
thing by yourself hoping for the
government to fix your life hoping for
student loan forgiveness to be the
Saving Grace
so go sign up for one of our personality
classes right now whether it's mine or
someone else's I just want you guys to
be a part of one of these go to fpu.com
sign up today the spots are limited that
is fpu.com
all right let's get back to the phones
will joins us up next in Philadelphia
Pennsylvania well welcome to the show
hey George how are you I'm doing well
how are you
I'm doing good uh thanks for taking my
call I just I'll try to be pretty brief
with this I work as a CRNA and so and I
worked as a CNA in Philadelphia but I
recently changed jobs and now I work out
of Allentown Pennsylvania
the reason why I changed jobs was
they're offering a very nice sign-on
bonus a change in schedule and the
retirement packages pretty awesome
um they contribute 20.6 percent of my
annual salary
free money at the end of the year so wow
I was just in a kind of a predicament
because
taking this job means our family will
have to move out of Philadelphia because
it's an hour 15 minutes each way to
commute
yes so the schedule is nice the
retirement uh package is nice the
sign-on bonus would mean that we will be
debt free besides our house
and I'm just kind of in a bind of what
to do and also we're in Philadelphia our
area isn't really doing the best there's
just a gun there was this uh gunshot on
our block so high crime area
yeah well it's not like high high Ed but
I mean there were gunshots on our block
so and you've got little kids and I have
a 13 month old yes oh so it's not really
the place where you can just send them
out and go run around the block well
what's holding you guys there why not
just move well our mortgage is nice
right now that's a problem
where our mortgage is probably about
like 1500 a month
so
and I wanted to pay off all our debts
first and we will move pretty soon but
the home expense the homes in those
areas are pretty high so if you moved
towards Allentown what would your rent
be if you rented for a while if we
rented for a while I would assume it's
around 12 to 1400 okay
I'm not gonna hang on to this life
because of the mortgage if I'm in your
shoes I don't think it's worth it
because if you're saying the mortgage is
nice but we can rent cheaper and you
could get a house later on down the road
once you're debt free do it the right
way go slow and maybe interest rates
change maybe they don't and maybe we
refinance down the line when they do go
down but man I'm not gonna I think your
mental health is going to deteriorate
yeah you're gonna have more time with
your family you're gonna have a better
life you're going to be in a safer
Community you're going to have your
mental health back because two and a
half hours in a car I just don't think
humans were meant for that kind of Life
long term now we can do it for a season
I think so either you can stick this out
for three months but this is no
long-term plan just because of the more
so I'm gonna start talking to my wife
going hey we need to figure out a game
plan to get out of here here's what I'm
thinking what do you think about this
let's go check out that area let's go
check out the neighborhood let's go find
this apartment and this is a season
we're going to find ourselves in as we
pay off debt because I'm guessing if you
sold the house you could pay off all
your debt
I think so I think so and we I think we
could pay off our debt now from the
sign-on bonus that's amazing we could
pay it off now and then the retirement
package I will make 180 a year so they
contribute 20.6 so that's roughly like
35 000 plus a year of free money that's
incredible
that's why I'm just like okay every all
the stones are in place let's just do do
it by default time that's what we were
thinking I just wanted I would be making
the trip to Allentown this weekend to
start looking at apartments
yeah yeah and that's a beautiful area
I've spent a lot of time over there
yeah it is there's some nice
neighborhoods outside Valentine and
around there yeah so I would let go of
the like I'm gonna do this because of
the mortgage because that's really the
only reason I heard and we would be away
from family a little bit but other than
that we wouldn't be too far it's like a
half hour to 45 minutes if we weren't to
pick Allentown if we were to be in the
middle which is still fine well they
come to you now they want to get out of
the city they want to see their 13 month
old so that's on them now for a little
while maybe down the line you go all
right we're going back to Philadelphia
one day but my guess is you guys love it
out there and you plant some Roots over
there
gotcha okay
thanks George I appreciate it thanks man
thanks for the call
all right let's take one more we've got
Jordan in Salem Oregon Jordan welcome to
the show
Jordan the orange it's a pleasure to
talk to you yep me too man sorry we're
right up against the clock get right to
the question
um so I have several credit card debts
that I have uh stopped paying on and
they went to collections and I'm
wondering if I should try to negotiate
and pay them off or if I should just let
them get cleared after seven years and
if that will affect my credit score at
all yeah it'll tank your credit score
what how much debt is in collections
uh around 12 000. how much money do you
have today
uh not a lot around two thousand okay
so number one we need to get our savings
up I don't know that they'll negotiate
with you at this point how old are these
debts
um around six months old okay so they're
pretty fresh I don't think they're gonna
negotiate on debt that's six months old
if it was six years old they may take
two grand and be done with it
but right now I would be proactively
communicating with them saying hey
here's how much I have it's not a lot
I'm working on it here's how much I can
give you today yeah but I would not give
them access to your checking account and
if they do give you any numbers get it
in writing
yeah absolutely those are the two main
things I'm getting married at the end of
the year and I'm trying to buy a house
as soon as possible listen my main
motivator right now we got to focus on
one thing at a time obviously the
wedding's gonna happen the home
ownership dream may be delayed we got to
clean up this mess do you have any other
debt oh for sure for sure
um no no just the credit card debts okay
so let's stay out of debt close all the
accounts let's make make some
arrangements with them be proactive
don't wait on them to to knock on your
door metaphorically speaking and you can
look up the Fair Credit collection act
if you want some kind of hard data on
what they can legally do and can't do
but I wouldn't Bank on them negotiating
I'd rather you just come up with 12
Grand and be done with it man and quit
playing this game I'm rooting for you
that puts this hour of the Ramsay show
in the books we'll be back before you
know it
[Music]
hey it's George Campbell if you like
what you heard in this episode and want
to know more about getting started on
the Ramsay baby steps go to
ramsesolutions.com and click on the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
well do work that they love and create
amazing relationships I'm your host
George Campbell flying solo this hour as
the team is off around the world
changing the world doing amazing things
I wanted to be here with you guys and
the phone lines are open at triple eight
eight two five five two two five if you
want to call in with your burning money
questions maybe you saw an ad on
Instagram and it felt like a scammy
financial product and you're just not
sure maybe you're trying to get out of
debt and you want to know the best way
or you want to invest but there's so
much noise out there you don't know what
to do who to trust and you just want to
make a decision with some confidence I
want to help you make those decisions
today Janessa kicks us off in Reno
Nevada Janessa welcome to the Ramsey
Show
hi thank you so much so basically my
question is I got myself in a sticky
situation
um I have some financial debt with some
credit cards and I have car payments and
everything and I just want to kind of be
the chain breaker of financial
irresponsibility and so I'm looking for
some ways to kind of budget and really
like make financial decisions properly I
love it that is a very Noble goal and a
great why
so let's talk through this so you have
credit cards and car loans how much
my car loan that's left is about 18
000 and then my credit cards all
together is like around 2 000. okay and
then um I also have a school loan as
well
um which I think what's left on that is
like around nine thousand okay and
what's your income
let's see so that's the thing it's
fluctuating because my my school loan
I'm in licensed esthetician and so I'm
starting out my career basically and I
am an independent contractor so it's so
up and down I make roughly like around
700 a month
you make 700 a month
yeah how is that possible
just because uh clientele and everything
is just so uh not but your book
appointments right I do yeah so you know
when you don't have appointments
correct so what are you doing when you
don't have appointments so I for a long
time I work another job like I worked
multiple jobs okay
um and usually that helps I just am
tired of being like at the bottom of the
barrel like making 14 an hour to where
it just doesn't really make you don't
even make 14 an hour now
no well kind of when I had like on my
good days I mean you make 14 an hour
three hours a week
I mean this you're way below the poverty
level
yeah so right now we need to get a
full-time job and do your esthetician
work on the side as we build that up and
build up the clientele
and maybe that means we pack out a
Saturday full of appointments and Monday
through Friday we've got a full-time gig
yeah and this may be temporary right now
you called in saying I'm in a mess of
debt and making 700 bucks a month means
you can't even cover rent let alone your
debt payments
well and the thing is is when I did like
I purchased my car and everything I was
working full-time so I wasn't like
irresponsible and like oh yeah I can't
afford this sure what were you doing
before yeah
um I was an HOA manager okay um yeah
what were you making doing that
not very much like 16 an hour okay
so this car that you've got 18 left on
what is it worth
um 22. okay
how much money do you have in the bank
total
about a hundred and forty dollars
currently yeah okay and that's all the
money to your name that's liquid right
okay
so our A1 is to go make as much money as
possible very quickly
how are you going to cover you have rent
payments no where are you living
with my parents okay how old are you
20. okay
so here's my game plan if I'm in your
shoes right now you have the blessing of
having very little bills which is why
you've been able to survive
right if you were on your own right now
you would be homeless for telling the
truth
or finding family and friends to live
with and so luckily you've got a lot of
time on your side and I want you to have
an amazing career as an esthetician but
right now we've got to clean up this
mess because I feel the weight of this
and I bet you do too
yeah and so to me that car's got to go
and that means we're gonna sell for 22.
you have 18 left that's going to leave
you with four thousand dollars right
and whatever any other money we can
scrape up we're gonna go get a four
thousand dollar car
and can I tell you that car is going to
be the worst looking car you've ever
seen in your life yeah you know how bad
how bad that car is going to look but
it's going to get you from A to B which
right now is just getting to work and
back home right
mm-hmm but guess what else that does
that means you have two thousand dollars
in credit cards and nine thousand
dollars in student loans that brings
your debt down to 11 total
and you already feel that weight leaving
your body don't you yes and now our goal
is how do we get rid of that next
smallest debt which would be the credit
cards do you have multiple or is it just
one
the trunk of it hold on you said you had
two thousand in credit cards
yeah I still have the eighteen thousand
and then well I guess plus I mean 1800.
so your next smallest debt is eighteen
hundred dollars
correct if you sell this car which I
think this thing's gone tomorrow we're
gonna clean it up take some nice pics
and we're gonna sell it private party
for as much as we can get for it
because right now that car is more than
you making an entire year
yeah and it's going down in value every
single day
or it could Propel you towards that
freedom if we sold it
and I want you to have a nice car down
the line when you're debt free and you
have an emergency fund we are going to
get Janessa an awesome car when her
career is taken off as an esthetician
and so I think right now we can still
work on the esthetician gig but right
now we need something full-time that's
going to bring a lot of money fast
yeah and that might mean three side jobs
or it might mean one full-time job
making 16 18 20 bucks an hour
okay okay so that would be my next goal
is go find a full-time job
while doing esthetician work on the side
and building up your clientele list
yeah
because right now there's a time to be
an entrepreneur and work on building
your client base but right now you can't
even think about that when you've got
debt payments coming out your eyeballs
right and so I just want you to focus on
one thing at a time because that's
what's helped me get out of debt at
forty thousand dollars worth of debt
which is way more than you had and uh
you know I was at a starter salary and I
was doing every side gig Under the Sun
anyone who would throw a buck at me I
was like all right I'll do what do you
need me to do and I tried to serve them
well and they told their friends and I
got more gigs that way and I think
you're going to do the same
yeah thank you I want to help you with
this Janessa hang on the line I'm gonna
gift you one year of Financial Peace
University if you want to join my class
starting June 20th if you can do that
and I'm also going to gift you one year
of every dollar plus to start making a
plan for every single one of those
dollars whether it's 700 or 7 000 you're
gonna have a plan and right now that
plan is to pay off all this debt while
you have the blessing of living at home
with very little expenses so I'm
cheering you on please call us back when
you're debt free and we'll celebrate
with you this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
[Applause]
y'all there's a lot you can't control
when it comes to health care but there
is something you should check out that
can help Christian Healthcare Ministries
chm is not Insurance it is
budget-friendly biblically based Health
cost sharing that means a community of
members helping share the burden of each
other's health care costs they help
people just like you in all 50 states so
see a chm could be right for your family
learn more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George camel the number to call is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five you jump in we'll talk about life
and money
listen if you're listening to the show I
assume that you enjoy it and if you do
enjoy it please consider hitting the
Subscribe button or the follow button or
whatever you're hanging out with us
leave a review let us know what you
think of the show and share it with a
friend and all of that is not for our
own validation and approval and ego it's
so that the algorithm spreads the word
about the show other people hear about
the show other people are impacted and
if it means one other person becomes
debt free and finds freedom from this
toxic money culture that is a win in my
book
and also if you're a fan of the show you
might like my brand new YouTube channel
where we're publishing new episodes
Mondays Wednesdays and Fridays three a
week and they are short they're funny
they are so hopefully helpful as we
break down some of these money Trends
and traps that you all are asking me
about sending me videos about we just
had a video this week about Apple's new
trick to get you to spend more through
their high yield savings account and
their credit card
and we also cover money traps that are
keeping the middle class broke I react
to some of Steve Harvey's money advice
from Family Feud we talk about how your
car is robbing you of six million
dollars so much stuff so go check it out
we've got tons of videos out there and
thank you to all of you who have already
subscribed and those of you who have
viewed the videos we hit a million views
just in the last month alone so thank
you so much the response to this has
been incredible and I encourage you guys
to go check that out hit the Subscribe
button and tell your friends apparently
kids really love the show I don't know
why I would rate it as a PG show you
know hey my mom texted me yesterday that
she loves your channel judges child's
our producer his mom loves the show that
means the world oh my goodness so
there's something for everyone here
whether you're you know you're six or
you're 56 everyone loves it so
appreciate that we try to deliver the
goods with our amazing team of editors
and writers and audio engineers and the
video guys it's a spectacle to behold
how much effort it takes to give you
guys some great content let's get to the
phones Robin joins us in Orlando Florida
up next Robin how you doing
I'm doing well how are you doing great
how can I help
I am trying to figure out when is a good
time to start saving for a house we have
190 000 in debt
um and we just want to know when we can
start saving for a house or if we need
to get all of our debt paid before we
start saving for a house
I can't breathe thinking about having a
mortgage on top of 190 000 in Consumer
Debt
doesn't that feel like a lot
it is a lot
a lot is what kind of debt is this
um a hundred thousand of it is student
loans
UH 60 000 is our cars and
12 000 is credit card okay and then I
have like 4 000 in taxes that I'm
currently paying okay and what's the
household income
uh we make currently 190 000 a year plus
extra with all of the side gigs my
husband does that is wonderful okay so
the good news is you guys have a big
shovel
yes the bad news is we have a load of
manure to clean up before we get into
home ownership
and here's why it's not because I'm
legalistic and I'm like you got to
follow the rent you gotta it's because
we take too many calls of the robins
that call in and they go hey we just got
a house it was our dream we thought it
was going to be this huge blessing and
we can't breathe
we have 190 000 in Consumer Debt the
mortgage 250 000 by the time the bills
are paid we can barely eat
and that is my fear for you guys even
with a great income you can out earn
your stupidity for a while
but man it'll drag you down having all
those payments
so what are your monthly payments just
on your debt
just the minimum payments we just
started the baby stuff on uh
a month ago this month uh but we our
minimums are uh I think all together
it's like 3 000 is our minimums on all
of our debts okay what's your take-home
pay
each month uh
each month we bring in about 15
000. love it okay that tells me there's
plenty of margin to start attacking this
debt
so just just this month we pay 4 000 in
credit card debt off awesome
so you're following the Ramsay plan
you're on board but you're like hey I
really want to get a house do we have to
wait till the stats paid off
yeah it's because we're in that we're in
a weird situation with our house our
friend slash my husband's boss
Splash our homeowner is the person that
owns the house oh it's all the same
person
it's all the same person
in your renting so it'd be like me
renting from Dave Ramsey
yes and he is he is great he doesn't
give us any hard time and he doesn't
care what happens to the house but I
would just like to be out of that
situation just so it doesn't ruin a
friendship well why don't you guys go
rent somewhere else
while you pay off this debt
because the rent in Orlando is
ridiculously high so you're getting a
deal right now and we have a kid and a
dog yeah we're paying what he pays for
his mortgage oh my goodness
so you want to have the cake and eat it
too Robin is that what's going on here
yes I would love to well here's the
thing I think the dream of home
ownership is on the horizon but I think
we need to pause and go how quickly
could we clean up this mess making 190
000 how quickly can you pay off 190 000.
what's your guess the plan that I
originally had
um all of all of 190 000 it was up to
pay it all off I don't buy it you guys
can do better than that
and that was being very can you live off
of 90.
yeah we can for sure live off of 90. so
you could throw a hundred total per year
at 190 000. that's less than two years
yes
we can definitely do that
free time we're going
yes of course there's taxes so this
again this is napkin math but I'm going
if you did the extra side gigs we live
off nothing we pause all investing we
sell everything that's not tied down how
much quicker can we do this because
think about this now the goal is if we
pay this off faster we get into that new
home faster
if we get into the new home now now
we're kind of comfortable while also
being uncomfortable because we're
stressed but we have the house but yet
our life kind of sucks
you see the other side here versus I do
24 months from now we're in a different
place
do you guys have any cash yeah
uh we just have 4 000 in the bank
account I cleared as much as I could out
without bankrupting us okay
the other option here I don't know that
you'll do it I don't know you're gonna
like it but you could sell the cars and
get cheaper cars
we're upside down
the cars okay but still even if you had
to get a loan from a credit union to
cover the difference
that would put you in ten thousand
dollars worth of debt instead of 60
right
that's true yeah so that still clears 50
Grand very quickly
and remember two years from now or less
now if we sold the cars we're debt free
then we're gonna get that emergency fund
in place real quick in less than six
months is what it takes on average then
we can start saving up for that down
payment
and then making 200 plus how quickly
could you save up a down payment if you
didn't have any payments in the world
uh
very quickly less than two years
yes and I I am about to start working
um because I'm currently not working
that's just so my husband I am going to
start working in September awesome what
do you think you'll make two thousand a
year
52 52 000. awesome so now think about
this Robin two years from now we're debt
free six months later emergency fund
less than two years after that we've got
the full down payment which means four
years from now you're in a completely
different place financially and that's
without even your income getting added
to this
so there's your options we can get into
the house today and have it be a curse
instead of a blessing or we can hit
pause and have some delayed
gratification and go man it's going to
be such a different picture if we do
this slow and do it the right way
and that's what I want for you
I will do that should I start saving any
money now or should I just wait till
it's all all that that's paid all the
money is going towards the debt what I
found is when I focus on 17 things at
once I kind of suck at all of them when
I put all of my energy
spiritually emotionally physically
mentally financially towards one thing
that thing gets busted through real
quick and that's what happens that's why
people follow our plan it's not a magic
plan it's just because we're stopping
doing 17 things at once and we're going
this debt is gone tomorrow and that next
debt is gone the next day and all of a
sudden you start Building Wealth you
start feeling the peace you become debt
free thanks so much for the call this is
the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
guarantee and shipping is always free
see whyblinds.com is the number one
online retailer of custom window
coverings go to blinds.com now and save
40 off selected products visit
blinds.com today for more info
foreign
[Music]
this is the Ramsey Show I'm George
Campbell hosting solo this hour give me
a call at triple eight eight two five
five two two five we'll talk about your
life and your money
our question of the day is brought to
you by neighborly your hub for Home
Services with 19 service Brands
Nationwide their network of providers
have trusted local service professionals
to handle more than a thousand different
services in and around your home visit
neighborly.com to find and schedule
service today today's question comes
from Jimmy in Rhode Island he asks is
Paypal trustworthy to keep doing my
online banking I've been using it for
over a year now and haven't had any
issues I noticed they have a PayPal
savings now it has a 4.15 apy seems high
for just the savings account maybe there
are some details I'm missing I want to
put 10 000 in it and see what happens
I'm not ready to invest the 10 000
completely so to me this seems like a
smart move what are your thoughts
great question Jimmy
okay so what he's talking about here is
using PayPal as a sort of banking system
now PayPal itself is not a bank they do
partner with other Banks like Bancorp
and Synchrony Bank to provide products
like some prepaid debit cards credit
cards lines of credit lots of debt
products that I would never recommend
you uh go towards but they also now have
a savings account which is also going to
be backed by Synchrony Bank which is a
member FDIC which means it's insured up
to 250 000 per deposit or per account
per ownership category and so there's
nothing wrong with having it as a
savings account I would however not use
it as a checking account because it's
really not a checking account I would
just use a Traditional Bank to do my
checking
and here's why they don't have the same
features they're not backed the same way
so really what you're doing is you have
a PayPal balance and you're kind of
using that as a checking account which
just doesn't make sense from a budgeting
perspective from a personal finance
perspective so I would stick with a
checking account I like to have a local
brick and mortar bank or credit union I
can go to if a problem arises I can talk
to someone face to face but I also like
to have an online high yield savings
account
now I don't trust PayPal just on a level
of there's been too many issues scams
Frozen accounts money disappearing eBay
scams that are connected to PayPal and
so if I were you I just wouldn't put my
money there as a savings account you can
get 4.15 these days at other places like
Marcus or Ally and again those are going
to be FDIC insured as well so your
money's safe there but I wouldn't be
using it'd be like using venmo as your
checking account it's just not a good
way to do it and you've got to hope you
have the money and you can do better
than that Jimmy but great question love
it all right let's go to Mike in
Philadelphia Mike welcome to the Ramsay
show
Hi how are you doing doing great what's
going on with you all right so yesterday
my sister called me and said her car
broke down my wife and I do really well
financially and and my sister's been
doing great on her own financially her
husband passed away probably four or
five years ago so she's a single mom of
three and she says to me she's like I
don't have enough money to buy a new car
so I'd love to help her out and I don't
know if it's like the best idea because
I have probably 15 000 I could just
write her a check today here you go I I
don't I don't think she wants to buy a
15 000 car so she's looking at thirty
thousand dollar range and I could give
her the money but I don't have it today
probably take me another two months to
get to get up to that point and I don't
know if I'd be doing her a disservice
and say Hey listen I'm just going to
give you 15 000 today take out a car
loan or option b buy a fifteen thousand
dollar car or and then you know you
probably have to sell it or two I feel
like that's kind of a waste of money
so I just don't know and I called I
called the Ramsey Show because I know
you guys like to say you know live like
no one else you can give like no one
else I'm just not quite ready to you
know like all my bills have been paid
and that happened about a year ago and
I'm and you know we've been saving but
we're not we're not at the point where
we can just give a 30 000 gift sure in a
moment service is this the first time
she's asked for money
yeah she didn't even ask for money she
just said I need you know I need some
help maybe you could help me look for a
car she thinks she wants to go get a car
loan I'm like I really don't want you to
get a car loan and you know for the
position that we're in
I'm almost intended to be like okay
listen get a car loan and then you know
I'll give you fifteen thousand dollars
for a down payment and then in you know
three months I'll just pay the pay the
loan off I don't like any of this Mike
there's got to be another option here so
what's wrong with the car currently
so her car is a 200 like seven with like
200 000 miles on it and the engine blew
yesterday okay so what's the cost
it was like
I think they said it was like 3 500.
okay and what's the car worth
if you let's say you put the engine back
in
yeah it's basically worth scrap okay
it's all pinged up and you know she's
got but if you put 3 500 in would that
thing run for another 50 000 miles
I have no idea and you know but we could
do that and I just feel like that's
wasting 3500
so we're gonna waste 30 000 instead
on a on a car
yeah I mean that feels like a crazy jump
did she say she wants a thirty thousand
dollar car where did these numbers come
from
yeah so she's like I want to oh she was
looking at a used
um Honda Pilot okay and you know like 40
000 miles
relatively new it was like in that
thirty thousand neighborhood
apparently that's a pretty good car I
feel comfortable with you driving it
like I said she's got the the kids and
honestly I'd love to give it to her
and I just really haven't been focused
on saving cash
so it's like if I just focus for two or
three months boom I just write out a
check here you go do you guys have no
debt in a fully funded emergency fund
yeah yeah even my my checking account is
pretty good so we paid off the house we
don't have a mortgage awesome but are
they student loans
um Mike what's the end game for her
that's what I'm worried about what
happens when she has another bill on
another emergency and she goes hey Mike
come on doing great she's been doing
great it's like her husband passed away
three years ago okay and she's been
doing great
uh financials she's not in that she saw
as a mortgage and she has a ten thousand
dollar emergency fund so she was saying
I'm going to use the emergency fund this
is an emergency okay and I'm like yeah
all right so you know maybe she uses the
emergency fund to help her out a little
we get a little bit of a cheaper car but
I'm like I just want to do this and I'm
I feel like I'm just right at the Finish
Line you know if she said this to me in
September I would be like here's a car
here are the keys here's what I would do
in your shoes Mike she has an emergency
fund I want her to have skin in the game
and I also don't want her to go into
debt so the condition for you giving her
is money it would be this is a gift I'm
going to give you fifteen thousand
dollars you use your emergency fund on
top of that to get the car you want but
do not go into debt and you go with her
and you help her negotiate and you help
her get that car but we're not going to
go into debt we don't need a thirty
thousand dollar car because we've been
driving around a clunker it doesn't work
like that
I think I think what is it what's her
income when you give family like you
don't get family alone you just give
them I never said to alone I said this
is a gift under the condition we don't
go into debt for a car so you're not
asking for the money back but she's also
putting in 10.
so she rebuilds the emergency fund over
the next six months
three months whatever it takes and we're
back
I don't see the problem here
so you think just like don't worry about
getting the car
that really that she wants and I think
it would be good for her
what's good for her
well so she you know getting a bigger
vehicle that's reliable oh my God you
don't have to think about it guess what
an older Honda Pilot with a hundred
thousand miles is just as reliable
you pay for the inspection by a
reputable mechanic it's going to cost
you 150 bucks and they go hey it's in
great shape this thing will go 250 000
miles but this idea that we need to get
the 2019 Honda Pilot because it's got
the TV in the back
I'm not buying that and so I think we
get the older car that we can pay for in
cash that's reasonable and I don't want
I don't want a gift to turn into enable
use your emergency fund this is an
emergency she needs a new car and then
from then on you go hey we're gonna set
up a sinking fund we're gonna put money
away every month because we know we're
gonna need a car eventually so that's
what I would do in your shoes you do
what you want to do but I would not go
into debt and I would not go buy a 30
000 car and I wouldn't use my money to
do it that would turn a gift into
enabling and that part scares me a
little bit but thanks for the call Mike
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the Ramsay show I'm
George Campbell hosting solo today keep
me company give me a call Triple eight
eight two five five two two five is the
number to call we'll talk about your
life and your money
you know what would be awesome never
having to use my own money to buy stuff
wouldn't that be nice and while that's
never going to happen for me it could
happen for you because we are giving you
the chance to win some of Dave Ramsey's
money in the Ramsay cash giveaway all
month long you can enter to win up to
500 bucks or the grand prize of three
thousand dollars for real all you got to
do is go to ramseysolutions.com giveaway
and bonus you can enter every single day
to increase your chance of winning no
purchase necessary but you got to be 18
or older to win and today just keeps
getting better because our ten dollar
sale is back and right now you can get
all the books and tools you need to
start Building Wealth find a career you
love improve your mental health and
deepen your relationships wouldn't that
be nice
the 10 sale includes Dave's latest book
baby steps millionaires that lays out
the stories of real people including
teachers who became millionaires using
the baby steps and you can do this too
that's some deep life-changing stuff for
the cost of a trip to Chipotle so shop
the ten dollar sale today at
ramseysolutions.com store
Danielle joins us up next in Pittsburgh
Danielle welcome to the show how you
doing
how are you great how can I help today
so my husband
and a jury we're on baby step number two
and we've paid off
um about forty thousand dollars
um in debt and we're on our
um our car loan now that's about 21
Grand and then we also have um a
mortgage as well as a second mortgage
that's actually for a building that my
husband owns for his small business
um but the question that I had for you
guys today or for you for that matter
um is just trying to navigate you know
paying off this debt but knowing that my
husband's a small business owner we
haven't been touching
um any of the money or kind of like
earnings we normally only take a little
bit out of there as we need we've been
using my income but we now have
um you know enough money sitting in his
bank account you know from you know his
great work that could be paying off some
of this debt I'm just not quite sure how
to navigate that yeah so what is this
all these retained earnings for what's
he saving up for with this business
oh originally were thinking about making
some changes to the building
but you know in talking about it it's
not going to really bring in extra
income and I don't think it's worth it I
agree um so the other thing was just
trying to like hold on to it knowing
that like he just really doesn't want to
take it out knowing that we'd be paying
taxes on it and if there's another
opportunity whether it's to pay down
um you know the business loan or
mortgage that he has on the building or
you know if it is smarter to put it back
into the building but I'm like we're
also sitting on this car loan
um how was he not paying taxes on it
I think it's just a matter of like
normally at the end of the year we have
the conversation or I'm like okay here's
what we're sitting on we want to throw
this into but I mean it's not stocks
this is earned income this is revenue
right so you got to report all this on
the taxes
well I think that's where like we tend
to meet with the accountant throughout
the year guys okay is there anything
else we want to be investing in whether
it's you know putting another barber he
is a barber shop it's putting another
chair in whether it's additional
advertising like we tend to play around
with the expenses and say okay do we
want to dump this back in which is where
there was the conversation or I'm like
fixing up the back room updating the
bathroom putting in putting on new
asphalt things like that got it none of
it is like immediate though but that's
10 like that tends to be what we're
doing how much money in this account
right now 28 000. and what's your total
debt load that's left
um you just have the car loan right the
mortgages we're going to put in baby
step six that's later on
yeah so right now the car has just about
21 000. so I would pay off the car today
and you still have seven thousand left
and as in a savings account for the
business and as long as he doesn't need
any retained earnings I mean you can
start chugging away at the mortgage too
but his income counts as y'all's income
and so I would use it towards your
shared goals which includes paying off
the house early
yeah so I guess the point too would be
just like sitting is that enough for
taxes knowing that we're using this for
personal stuff but even then we'd still
have enough to pay it off is he filing
quarterly estimated taxes right now
he is yeah okay so I would make sure we
have enough to cover this next quarter
but you're for sure going to have enough
right now to just pay off the car
okay and if unless he has a specific
goal he's saving towards in the business
and some retained earnings for whatever
you know the expenses may be in that
business I would be using it to further
yourselves in the baby steps and uh get
that emergency fund in place do you guys
have any other cash outside of that 28k
um now we've kept it to a minimum trying
to dump it all on debt okay we just have
like you know our little baby emerging
so maybe the next thing is we pay off
the car that's 21 we use another five to
get our emergency fund going for baby
step three keep fully funding that with
future income and then beyond that we're
going to be at four five six we should
be investing 15 of our income into
retirement and paying off the house
early
and then should we be treating the the
business loan on the building the same
way we treat the mortgage then
yeah I would probably focus on paying
off your mortgage first depending on the
numbers uh if they're equal and you want
to attack that the business mortgage but
I'm going to just put them all in that
kind of baby step six category once we
get rid of this Consumer Debt
that's really helpful thank you awesome
thanks so much Danielle great question
we we love a barber I love my barber he
started his own business and branched
off and we need those entrepreneurs in
this world today all right let's go to
Landon in Columbus Ohio Landon welcome
to the show
hey thanks for taking my call sure um
just got a kind of a similar question
um so uh me and my wife wife a
stay-at-home mom I make annually 180
plus thousand a year awesome um that I
have is my mortgage which I owe 157 on
and then I have a car loan that I was
probably young and dumb and bought I
just followed you guys about five months
and I'm trying to figure out whether I
should keep the car
and pay it off or trade it in for
something Less in value and start
banging out the house
okay what's left on the car loan
the car line was a Chevy Tahoe and I owe
57 on
and that's your only vehicle or do you
have multiple
um we have another vehicle that's paid
off
um just a Ford Fusion
um what's that worth a little bit now
about fifteen thousand dollars okay
so as far as the numbers go you know
these cars still don't add up to half
your income which is kind of our
parameters for things with wheels and
Motors in them so they're not they're
not killing you but I also feel like you
don't need the Tahoe and you're kind of
sick of making these payments and you
want to be debt free faster
is that fair right it's our goal is to
pay off the house
but we bought Tahoe so we can haul a
family and kids around you know how many
kids you got um
two-thirds you need a Tahoe for two kids
I thought you were gonna say you got six
kids
no two kids
um so we don't need it so we can settle
for less but a CRV can haul two kids
right so yeah
traded in and settle for less or just
since it's my only day other than the
house it's probably the hurry up what
would the Tahoe sell for
um probably about what I owe and I
haven't owned it left on probably about
three months I've owned it okay and how
much money do you have outside of that
do you have any money in the bank
um yeah emergency fund and the bank I
have about seventeen thousand dollars
okay
so if you sold this thing for 57 that
leaves you with zero dollars owed and no
car
so I would use some of that money you
have sitting and savings to go get you a
car and that might mean you save for
another month or two and we downgrade to
an SUV for now
until okay
we got that Fusion that I was talking
about and my wife should stay at home so
she's not really going anywhere if I'm
at work have you talked to her about
that that worries me that she can't
leave the house because you're at work
that's what we talked about maybe
bind is a little crappy work traveler
car for me and then she can keep this
Fusion okay um that sounds better now
maybe soon enough more than mama's
always got to have the nicer cars that's
a rule
right man if you're willing to make that
kind of sacrifice it's going to propel
your wealth building Journey
okay so I would get a cheap car for now
make sure you get a pre-purchase
inspection on it don't go buying a
clunker and then blaming me but that's
going to set you up for Success set you
up to get that fully funded emergency in
place begin investing 15 and get that
house paid off making 180 with no
payments you're going to pay that house
off in probably three years is my guess
and as young as you guys are it's going
to put you in a great financial spot
thank you so much for the call man that
puts this hour of the Ramsey Show in the
books my thanks to all the guys in the
booth we got Christian Austin Bob James
Andrew who knows who else is there
Zach's back there and you America thanks
for listening in we'll be back real soon
[Music]
camel here if you love the show and you
want a deeper dive on your money Journey
we've got a Weekly Newsletter that gives
you helpful articles and tips on
following the Ramsay way just go to
ramsaysolutions.com today to sign up for
the newsletter again that's
ramseysolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
ERS of Ramsey Solutions broadcasting
from the PODS moving and storage Studio
it's the Ramsay show where we help
people build wealth do work that they
love and create amazing relationships
I'm George Campbell joined by no one
this hour I'm solo holding down the fort
while our team is across America
changing lives impacting people and the
number to call if you want to join me is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five I just filmed some real juicy
behind the scenes Instagram of the
Ramsay show what we're seeing on the
desk what's going on in the booth so if
you want to go check that out it's at
George Campbell with a K on Instagram in
the stories for the next I don't know 24
hours however along the algorithms let
it stay alive so go check that out if
you want some behind the scenes it's fun
all right let's get to the phones
Samantha kicks us off in Spartanburg
North Carolina Samantha welcome to the
Ramsay show
hey George thanks for taking my call
happy to what's going on
um I
I had to question that do if you know do
I really need life insurance or can I
skip buying it
are you single
no I'm married
okay so what happens if Samantha God
forbid something happens to her
uh my husband would be fine why is that
um he wouldn't need to grieve he
wouldn't need to take any time off work
maybe to grieve I'm sure I mean but but
they're you know but we're kind of in a
position you know we own our home and we
have no debt
um so finances aren't really a problem
the only thing that I joke with them and
say I feel bad I feel like I need it
because if I die you know then wouldn't
he love to be a millionaire
oh if you have the life insurance in
place yeah I mean there's no real reason
I don't think financially for me to have
it well the time that where we would say
hey you don't need to get term life is
if you are self-insured which means if
something happened you had enough with
your assets with retirement in the bank
that you wouldn't skip a beat covering
the bills and replacing all of the value
that Samantha added to this family
and that's just that's not just income
right that's oh my gosh I got to hire
some help around the house like I can't
do this on my own
and so there's a lot of other people
even stay-at-home moms we recommend
having 25 uh 250 000 to 400 000 worth of
policy on a term life to cover the Mary
poppins-esque uh solution you would need
to cover all the things that
stay-at-home moms do right and so are
you currently working full-time outside
of the home
not full-time
um just part-time
um
no carries all the benefits that we need
okay um do you add any value to the home
well God yeah it was a trick question
yes and so you've got to think about
that aspect too of all the things that
you do around the house that he now has
to figure out while grieving your loss
and so that's the reason why we
recommend having it and honestly it is
so cheap that I I think you'll just
sleep better at night knowing there's a
big old pad of cash to cover us while we
grieve
okay so how old are you great advice at
34. okay you are exactly my age and I'll
tell you right now you could get
um a million dollar policy and it would
be like the cost of a pizza
wow it is not it's I mean a very nice
pizza at that uh so how what's your
what's your current income
mine is 60 000. okay so if you got a
policy that's 10 to 12 times your income
for the next 15 or 20 years you're
looking at a 600 000 policy for 15 or 20
years
yeah okay so you can jump onto
ramseysolutions.com and get a term life
insurance quote from our friends at
Xander insurance it's super easy it will
take you legitimately one minute
you'll say hey here's how healthy I am
here's my age here's what I'm looking at
and we'll spit out a bunch of quotes
from a bunch of different companies and
you can get it in place very quickly
awesome well thank you so much George
absolutely thanks for the call great
question and for those of you that are
going hey I'm not in Samantha's
situation or I don't know that I need it
or no one relies on my income uh the
moment someone does or even if you have
a bunch of debt and you know even think
about things like funeral costs
and putting that burden on someone to go
oh my gosh I'm grieving the loss of this
person I loved on top of having to you
know shell out thousands and thousands
of dollars it's a great thing to have in
place and term life is one of the most
affordable types of insurance that is
out there and I recommend everybody get
it you want 10 to 12 times your income
and you want a term of about 15 or 20
years because think about it if you
follow the Ramsay plan 15 or 20 years
from now you're out of debt with a paid
for house and you've been investing into
retirement for close to 15 years
so you become what we call self-insured
to where you don't need that money
because you've got a pile of it yourself
so great question and always connect
with our friends at Xander Insurance
that's who I use for all of my insurance
needs uh great folks over there with
some great rates because they shop
independently all right let's move to
Boise Michaela joins us there what's
going on Michaela
hi George thanks for taking my call
how can I help
my husband are getting ready to sell our
business and I guess I'm just wondering
if I should put the profit towards debt
or if I should save it for a down
payment for a house
ah exciting so what kind of business is
this
um it's a hoof trimming business for
dairy cattle wow so specific I love it
yeah what are you selling the business
for do you have a buyer
um yes we do okay so what will be the
net profit for you guys
South awesome
okay and you said you've got some debt
but you also want to buy a house how
much debt do you have
um we have about 30 000 in debt okay and
how much money do you have in the bank
um
I
uh probably close to ten thousand cool
so this is a pretty simple scenario now
number one if you're following the baby
steps the track would be pay off all
Consumer Debt then fully funded
emergency fund then down payment for a
house
and so if you follow that plan you're
making 38 from the sale the debt's 30
that leaves you with eight you already
have 10 in the bank is 18 000 uh fully
funded emergency fund for you guys three
to six months of expenses
um uh about yeah perfect
so right after this business is sold you
could be working on that down payment
but I would not use that money as a down
payment while you carry thirty thousand
dollars worth of debt
it's gonna slow you down in the long run
and I know you so badly want this house
don't you
yes you are ready and you're gonna get
there in no time when you don't have any
payments weighing you down and when you
do get that house you're gonna have one
payment to make and that is the mortgage
yeah and that is what I call Freedom so
how much longer would it take to save up
the down payment
debts are paid off not very long Booyah
what's your household income
um well with the trimming business it
was 90 000 but we started a new business
so it's going to be close to 120. oh my
gosh I love it okay and what's the down
payment goal you guys have
um I would say anywhere from 15 to 20
000. oh that's it
I don't know yeah well you I would set a
goal 15-year fixed rate mortgage that's
the only type I'd ever recommend for the
payments no more than a quarter of your
take-home pay that will help you dictate
how much down payment you need to maybe
30 000 maybe fifty thousand but making
120 with no payments you're gonna be
there within I would say I'm gonna give
it less than a year if you follow these
steps you pay off the debt you have the
emergency fund start saving up that down
payment in less than a year you're going
to have that down payment and you're
going to step into this house with such
peace and such Freedom thanks for the
call
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George Campbell co-hosting with no one
today hosting solo but you can catch me
co-hosting on Smart money happy hour and
hosting my own brand new YouTube channel
you can go check that out just search
George Campbell with a K over on YouTube
and I recently published a video called
warning avoid the modern day Gold Rush
and it's because anytime we get spooked
in America about the economy and what
the government's going to do and is the
dollar gonna hold its value people get
spooked and the fear monitors come out
and they tell you to run and buy gold so
here's a headline from CNBC Americans
think gold beat stocks as a long-term
investment
here's some key points the share of
Americans who think gold is the best
long-term investment almost doubled in
2023 to 26 percent according to Gallup
the share who prefers stocks declined to
18 however stocks are the better wealth
generator over long time Horizons
according to financial advisors and gold
is typically viewed as a safe haven
during times of fear
and here's a quote from Charlie
Fitzgerald who's a certified financial
planner he said as a long-term
investment gold is a very poor solution
it's that simple it's more like
speculation
stocks generally serve as the long-term
growth engine of Investment Portfolio
financial advisors said the S P 500
index of stocks had a 10.43 average
annual total return between 1970 and
2022 while gold had a 7.7 percent return
over the same period so here's the deal
a lot of people are turning to this
stuff because they're scared and I
posted this video and I didn't know that
there was such thing as gold Bros like
there are the crypto Bros but they came
out in full force in the comment section
on this video going like we never said
it was an investment it's a hedge
against inflation and what if the and I
don't trust the government and I just
smile and Nod and sleep well at night
while they freak out with I guess a pile
of gold in their bed I don't know what
they're doing with this stuff
and here's the deal We've joked about it
on the show but if it all went down
right because what they're assuming is
the stock market tanks let's say every
company in America went bankrupt and the
stock market went to zero and all of our
retirement accounts were zero that is an
apocalyptic situation
at that point when you have a pile of
gold I don't care I'm looking for food
and fuel and shelter and maybe ammo
depending on what's going on I don't
know if the Zombies come out at that
point who knows
but that's really the case so people
that are hanging on to Gold are saying
it's a hedge against inflation but long
term we know that the S P 500 the
General stock market is a way better
investment
and therefore what are you holding gold
for it's a terrible savings account
because you still got to go turn it into
money and the gold you bought probably
won't sell for what you paid for it
unless we're in a terrible economic time
but not at the point of collapse so I
just don't buy this argument I don't own
any gold I don't even own a gold chain
okay I don't think I could rock it if I
wanted to
so if I'm in your shoes I wouldn't be
buying gold and the people who are
telling you to run and buy it they have
ulterior motives and they're usually
like old guys yelling at you on TV that
you got to go buy gold right now and you
can get it from their website or
something so I would avoid it at all
costs and you can go check out that
YouTube video all eight minutes and 22
seconds and it's full glory and humor
over on my YouTube channel
all right let's take a call from Allison
in Richmond Virginia Allison welcome to
the show
hi George thanks for taking my call
absolutely what's going on
um I have a question
um I turned 60.
and I was thinking about selling my home
and buying an RV
why is that
so I could
I don't know travel
and um
cut down on expenses
are there other people involved here are
you single married
single okay so you want to get a big old
RV for Allison to Traverse the country
yes
but not no not a big one like just um
like the you know the little like a
little camper situation
yeah yeah well could you test this out
and maybe go rent an RV for a week or
two
before you go sell the house and make
this huge life change
well the only problem is the one that I
want
um you can't really test it out
it's there's none available for rent
that style
no not why maybe I'll have to research
it some more but okay
um I haven't really seen them I would do
the homework there now can you pay for
this RV in cash
no that's why I'm selling the house
this is what worries me the house is
going to maintain and appreciate in
value that RV is going to go down in
value
and that worries me as a retirement plan
so do you have any other Investments
um well I have uh I have a retirement
that I receive monthly how much is that
and um
it's about 2 000. is that Social
Security is that a pension
a pension pension
yeah okay
so what's your game plan long term in
order to retire and have money
um
that was kind of like the RV thing like
I was gonna
well you gotta eat you need gas you got
to have some experiences so are you are
you currently working are you already
retired
um semi I do some gig stuff and I work
seasonal okay
I would put pause on this until we have
more information and we have a better
financial plan do you have a financial
advisor that you're working with
currently
no no I just want to make sure that 80
year old Allison is happy with the
decisions that 60 year old Allison made
okay you know what I mean I don't want
you to do this impulsively you sell the
house now you lose that appreciating
asset the RV is going down in value we
don't really have anything invested
except for this two thousand dollar
pension that's coming in and all of a
sudden 15 years down the road we're
going oh my gosh what did I do I don't
have enough money to buy a house because
I put it on the RV which is now worth
half of what I paid for it and this is a
scary situation
hmm okay
so I would do I would do some homework
and I would make sure because people
travel all the time and they don't go
buy RVs to do it so there's a lot of
ways to travel the world
without having to sell your house to do
it so I just want to make sure you have
a place to land because I can't imagine
you're going to travel on an RV for the
next 20 years
I don't I never thought of that part
yeah that's all I'm just thinking if I'm
in Allison's shoes I'm thinking long
term I'm thinking man I really want to
retire with dignity I want to have money
I don't want to be having to work I want
to get to work
and that's a different mindset and it's
a different financial situation so I
think you're you're on the path I'm not
saying this doesn't happen I just want
to push pause do a whole lot of homework
you can go meet with one of our a
smartvester pro
which are financial advisors that we
trust to help you the Ramsey Way with
when it comes to investing so you can
get connected with a smartvester pro at
ramsaysolutions.com and click on trusted
pros and I'd also do some homework on
the RV and I would rent one before I
bought one because you may get into that
thing and say I hate driving around this
boat and having to sleep in a Walmart
parking lot or you might go oh my gosh
this is everything I hope to dream for
and here's how much it cost me for two
weeks so here's how much it's going to
cost me for six months and that's what
I'm hoping for you
well hey folks if you've never
experienced smart conference before let
me tell you you're missing out on this
thing this is Ramsay's biggest event of
the year and the event is packed with
inspiration motivation and information
we're talking how to get control of your
money improving your mental health
strengthening your relationships and
building a successful in career so
whether you're on baby step two or baby
step 7 with a paid for house you're
going to leave this event fired up and
smarter so get ready because our next
smart conference is happening in Chicago
this fall with all of our Ramsay
personalities Dave Ramsey Rachel Cruz Dr
John deloney Jade warshaw Ken Coleman
and myself at smart conference weekend
September 15th and 16th
and if you're lucky you might get to
witness a live recording of the smart
money Happy Hour podcast with Rachel
Cruz and I and you get to be a part of
that in the live studio audience and
right now our early bird general
admission ticket price is just 79 bucks
for an entire weekend that's insane and
we've got limited VIP and platinum
tickets so do not wait to get yours the
VIP ticket includes meet and greet with
Rachel John Jade Ken and me one of my
favorite parts of these events is
getting to meet all of you during the
breaks hearing your stories taking
pictures celebrating your success it's
always a highlight for me so go to
ramseysolutions.com events to get your
tickets today and I will see you at
smart conference in Chicago September
15th and 16th we'll be right back
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsay show I'm
George Campbell flying solo today and
I'm not alone we have a wonderful crowd
in the lobby and I assume they are here
for our newest friends on the debt free
stage Micah angia how are you guys great
George how are you doing wonderful where
are you guys from North Platte Nebraska
in the middle of nowhere there's a
little town that we call home that's
wonderful thanks for making the trip all
the way to do your dead free scream
absolutely absolutely how much debt did
you guys pay off we paid about 72 to 73
000 all right and how long did that take
roughly about 24ish months all right and
what was your range of income uh when we
got married
um it was probably about oh so I was
working covert award so probably
anywhere between 70 to 95. awesome okay
what kind of debt was this 72 was is a
mortgage in a house oh my gosh yep you
paid off your house
you guys are too young for that no no
we're not can I ask you how old you are
because America's wondering I'm 31 and
my wonderful wife is 26. I thought way
younger than me you guys are incredible
Okay so
we got to talk about this how did you
come to going like we're gonna pay this
house off at 26 and 31 most people are
going I'm going to hang on to a mortgage
as long as possible we're going to take
out the HELOC to do the renovations and
get the investment prop and you guys
just said we want to be done yeah what
happened
um it's really my wife's fault she got
me on word
um which has actually been a huge
blessing
um to take that journey and have her
be encouraging along the way how long
have you guys been married just about
two and a half years yep so you came
back from the honeymoon and nailed it
you were like we're getting out of debt
how do you even get a spouse on board
after post honeymoon go like were you
already on board with the Ramsay stuff
were you guys already debt free and yeah
so basically long story short what
happened was
um when I was 15 uh my dad ended up
passing away it's because you didn't
have enough money to buy the meds he
needed
and
um so when I got married I said nope
we're not doing this so I went to
college debt free
um I had siblings that did the Ramsay
plan and I saw that they always had
money and I was like this we gotta
figure this out and uh our my local
church at the time
um Mike Michelle led a class and I was
like yes
so I ended up taking the class when I
was in high school
um I worked jobs in college
um the Lord was just so gracious
and uh so many things happened
um but anyway we got married and
I remember going to him being like I
want to do this Ramsay plan and he's
like I don't even know Dave Ramsey in my
life this is common sense I don't need
someone telling me how to do this
and I was like Lord how do I do this
well he said watch me work and that was
the start
so we got married and I am like a super
nerd I am like nerdy of the nurse very
much yeah and and I'll own it it's okay
and I was like Lord like I want to pay
extra on this house and I want to get it
paid off and he wasn't against it he
just was like all right we'll do it and
I was working covidward and as a nurse
I'm a registered nurse and um Lord was
just like no more than two thousand
dollars on your extra payment
and so we did that I worked covidward
um but something changed
um my mental health went in the toilet
and
my husband finally looked at me and said
I don't care what it costs you need out
so I went down to work in part time and
I didn't get it I was like Lord like I
don't get this
and uh during that time period a friend
of ours came and lived with us and uh
because Micah told the Lord we'd never
do it so therefore we ended up doing it
which mind you that was nine months into
marriage so nine months into marriage we
had a guy come live with us he's like
hey I made some mistakes I need some
help and we were like absolutely come on
man man
so ah so he ended up living us for a few
months a few months later we're still
plugging away on our debt and then the
Lord's like hey by the way I'm gonna put
this on your heart uh we ended up also
bringing in a refugee family from
Ukraine so we went from a family of two
to a family of six with a dog overnight
oh my goodness for two months yeah so
that was a world one and a half uh there
was there was stress that was involved
um times we get frustrated with each
other but in the end we would never go
back on what we did and so during that
time I was still working part-time and
uh what ended up happening was I
actually ended up becoming their
Advocate I ended up becoming part lawyer
wow by God's grace we were able to get
them on their feet and with help of the
church but never once did we miss a
payment and never months did we miss an
extra payment and we made that 2 000
every time even with me missing work
like random things happened like he got
a Bonus at work or something happened
and so God was so clear and he was like
nope you're doing this and our grocery
bill never ballooned because we had
people in our church that partnered with
the Salvation Army so we were also
getting food donations on a weekly basis
incredible so like we said we haven't
missed anything nothing nothing ever
changed nothing ever changed so you guys
were super faithful Community showed up
God showed up on top of all of your hard
work and diligence yep and you paid this
thing off in two years well and then
after that about three weeks after we
ended up doing a camp called Royal
Family Kids Camp Royal Family Kids Camp
is Camp that loves kids in the foster
care system who have seen the worst of
the worst we literally helped a child
who literally watched their family get
shot and then got shot themselves
and in this Camp what we do is we treat
them like Royals for a week and we love
on them so I went as a nurse he went as
a big camper and God did so much we
actually have to pay to go to the camp
so that way the kids don't have to go or
have to pay to go and um God allowed
that to happen and so we got to do that
and it was so much fun so if you guys
see we're wearing shirts that say make
moments matter
and if I'm going to be really honest I'm
in my honest wife moment for a second
um last week when we were talking about
like how we wanted to do this and what
we wanted to share my lovely husband
comes to me and he says hey I think we
need to wear make moments matter shirts
and I was like
oh ah babe don't you think we might want
to wear something a little nicer or
something and he's like but babe that's
the whole reason we did this the whole
reason we did this is because we wanted
to make moments matter we want to be
able to serve servants and be available
for people wow and so that's why we do
this we do this because we want to make
moments matter not only for our family
and future generation but we want to be
able to be available for people because
never once did our giving budget change
never once did our payment stop
and this isn't any like Prosperity
Gospel this is not because oh we did
this because now Jesus will bless us
that's not how this works like there was
a lot of times I was scratching my head
being like I don't know how we're gonna
do this but okay like all right we'll do
it and the Lord was just so so faithful
well now you guys are debt free with no
payments you can make those moments
matter you realize very early on that it
was never about the money and this debt
payoff goals what could we do if we
don't have any payments it's not a life
we leave how many people could we help
and so you guys are such an inspiration
I'm so proud of you what do you tell
that couple that's sitting out there
with the mortgage and probably a bunch
of debt and they're going uh yeah but
we're not Michael Gia that's not us what
do you tell them the key to getting out
of debt is I mean I know we've heard it
said you stick to the budget and it's
not so much your financial decision as
it is your lifestyle choice right so for
us make moments matter that's that's
kind of become our lifestyle Chase as
well as serving the servants
but for the spouses who may not
necessarily be on board right away as
someone who also wasn't on board right
away
the Lord works wonderfully when someone
is persistent
and they're persistent in prayer with
that yeah and when they get on board
it's all the more exciting because then
I caught it and go okay yes what else
can we do to help push this out so it's
it's really I mean
it's hard work yeah yeah but in the end
it's it's worth it I'm curious what's
the house worth uh right now I think
sitting on the markets like 140ish 130
140. all yours
the next step for you guys is baby steps
millionaires as you continue to live and
give like no one else so we've got to
live and give box for you including
Dave's best seller baby steps
millionaires The Total Money Makeover so
you can get someone else's Journey
started and of course one year to
Financial Peace University to go through
this so proud of you guys you ready yeah
absolutely it's the moment we've all
been waiting for it's Micah angia 73
000 paid off house and everything in 24
months making 70 all the way up to 90.
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream three two one
[Applause]
oh I hope you're watching on YouTube
because this is a beautiful picture of
what love and freedom looks like and did
you hear that they hit a very deep why
it was more than just about money it was
more than just about them it was what
they could do for their family for their
Community for the kingdom and I'm so
inspired by this amazing young couple
out there and if they can do it you can
to America what's holding you back do
you need a deeper why do you need a
bigger shovel go do what it takes
because that kind of freedom is worth it
every time this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
welcome back to the Ramsey show our
scripture of the day comes from Isaiah
43 19.
see I am doing a new thing now it
Springs up do you not perceive it I am
making a way in the wilderness in
streams in the Wasteland
Justin Vernon of Bon Iver one of my
favorite artists said you never have to
change your scene when you're always
comfortable with evolving
love it
I'm inspired by Our Last dead freeze
cream and it reminded me of my story 10
years ago when I started here at Ramsey
and I was forty thousand dollars in debt
I was broad-eyed bushy-tailed and very
broke
and uh the system I realized was
designed to keep me broke I did
everything Society told me to do what my
parents told me to do my parents were
immigrants from the Middle East they
came they adapted to the American
culture very quickly and collected some
Consumer Debt and I thought I was real
frustrated I got real cynical I was
anxious I was a little bit hopeless
going like I'm forty thousand dollars in
debt and I did everything Society told
me to do and life just hasn't worked out
magically because I went to this right
school and took out the student loans
and I'm using my credit cards trying to
build my score and yet I don't feel like
I'm winning financially I'm not getting
ahead I'm not building my net worth I'm
just making credit card companies rich
and under the guise of my two percent
cash back and my Delta Sky Miles Card
and so when I realized hey it's my fault
and it's not all my fault but it is my
responsibility what am I going to do
next
and starting here at Ramsay Solutions in
2013 forty thousand dollars in debt
following the baby steps going through
Financial Peace University I paid off
that Consumer Debt in two years
following the debt snowball method got
my emergency fund in place I began
investing into our 401K here at Ramsey
and I realized oh my gosh I don't have
to play this game anymore I don't need
the credit score I don't need to hope to
do the credit card churning to get the
points to hope to go on the vacation one
day I can just save up and pay for my
own dang stuff and not have to wait on
the credit card companies to bless me
with their cash back freaking Rewards oh
and I don't have to have a mortgage for
30 or plus years I can get a 15-year
mortgage and then pay that off early
because I don't have any debt and I have
control of my income
that's a game changer so that helped me
realize oh my gosh you can Buck the
system entirely and on the other side of
that is Financial Freedom is financial
peace is life on my terms is margin is
options is joy and man that was a game
changer for me when I realized that and
that's what every single debt free
streamer up here realizes
and what you realize is it's way more
than money paying off debt is just the
secret we get you to get up on the stage
but what you do is you change your life
because you realize oh I can apply this
in every other area and what can I do
without payments it's not about the
money it's about what the money can do
it's just a tool
and I can now bless others I can give
outrageously I can retire early I can
retire with dignity
and that's what life is all about to me
it's not about just storing up a bunch
of money it's about way way more than
that
so I hope you guys get that when you
hear these debt free screams you feel it
in their Spirit something changes
something visceral something cathartic
and man there is such freedom in bucking
the system and going oh my gosh I can
rent a car with a debit card and just
pay for stuff and not have to worry
about what I bought three months ago and
do pay later I can just pay now and be
done with it and move on with my life
leaving mental space
and emotional energy and financial
margin to do the things I want to do man
that's freedom and so if you want a
piece of that that's what this show is
all about join Financial Peace
University if you want to dig into that
I'm leading a class starting June 20th
virtually
you can join at fpu.com
let's get to the phones Leticia joins us
in Washington D.C Leticia what's going
on
hey George this is so crazy that I get
to actually speak to you
um it's crazy for me too
yeah
all right let me get straight to the
point
um my husband and I are actually in 300
and 8 000 worth of debt most of it is
student loans yeah that's how we feel
when we look at it
um I'm currently working as a CNA in a
hospital and he works for the regulatory
Authority
um we want to know he's thinking that I
could I should go back and go to nursing
school
um and we should do it while we're
trying to get out of debt because you
know once I get a Nursing degree my
income would
uh increase exponentially however I feel
like we should tackle our debt first and
then you know maybe we could use my when
I go back that income that I get we
could use it for baby step three
um baby step 3B instead so I'm just
trying to see which is the smarter
decision
um and uh yeah we we live in DC so you
know our expenses are kind of high
anyway well we live in the DC area so
they're high and how did we go this far
into student loan debt who's to is this
a mix of your student loans
it's both of ours he has a bachelor's
and a master's and I have a bachelor's
in social work he has one in business
admin I mean he's using his degree I'm
currently not using mine but we also did
go to private Adventist colleges how
much was how much do loans did you take
uh so I think his master's was about
I mean I think it was like 90
say and undergrad was like 30 grand a
year
for both of us I'm just confused how
this adds up to 400 Grand
so interest we ignored it for a really
long time so it's been building PS so
we're we're very deep deep in a hole and
I don't think that we should
what's your household so I'm a 120 gross
so we bring about uh yeah 75 a month I
think but we have four kids too so two
oh boy it's a party over there okay yeah
how much money do you guys have in the
bank
uh just our thousand dollars
starting fun do you have any other kind
of debt
uh just a few medical bills one of our
kids was our latest child was in the
NICU for a while so that bill you know
they charged like it's a luxury hotels
but pretty large
um okay yeah so here's what I'm thinking
you guys are in a hole and right now
your husband's like let's just keep
digging and we'll get to China
eventually if we keep digging I thought
that as a kid doesn't work like that
and so I don't want you to dig this hole
any further because the fallacy is well
we'll go to nursing school we'll add
another 150 Grand but then my income
will go up by another 50 Grand
well we were
throughout
could pay out of pockets only about 5
000 a semester and I would get my
associates because I can still sit for
the NCLEX that way like you could
actually become a registered nurse but
if we if I go and get an associate that
would take all the money that we're
using and you're able to go to nursing
school take care of four kids and still
keep your full-time job
I I I don't think so but so that's what
worries me is you lower your income yeah
while this debt is accumulating interest
to hope that years down the line we
increase this income so I think what we
need to do right is find other ways to
increase income right now until we clean
this mess up then once we clean it up we
can look at cash flow in school
but we have cash flow enough school at
this I mean we've taken out enough debt
we've tried the school route let's try
to work our Tails offer out
right so we need to get this income up
because 389 making 120 that scares me
making 200 trying to pay 390. okay now
we got we're cooking now we can put 100
at the debt be done with this thing in
under four years
and if you've heard our friend Jade
warshaw story fellow Ramsay personality
they paid off what 465 000 worth of debt
in seven and a half years
and so your story may look more similar
to theirs where it doesn't take two
years it may take four or five years but
they also got their income up like crazy
they were doing 17 side hustles
so just work because I was thinking
maybe if we could lower our our expenses
maybe moving to a cheaper costing area I
mean that's a that's a huge key can you
guys do that with your jobs
we were thinking about relocating to
Georgia where our family where we have
some family there and my husband's job
is remote so it goes with him wherever
he goes as long as he doesn't leave the
United States I love it so if you guys
are willing to uproot your life to then
shave off 20 30 grand a year that will
change everything
and so if you're willing to do that I
would do it
yeah I don't think he's willing so yeah
because you guys are going to run out of
steam at this rate in D.C
we are already losing steam he's
completely out of hope so I I I I I I I
hear you well that that's going to be a
step in giving you guys hope and I also
want to gift you one year of Financial
Peace University I want you and your
husband to go through it because you
guys need some pep in your step yes you
need some income yes but you also need
to see the light at the end of this
tunnel so hang on the line Austin will
pick up and we'll gift you one year of
Financial Peace University as well as
one year of every dollar plus there's a
paycheck planning tool in there that I
want you to use a financial goals tool
to show you when you're going to become
debt free how to get there faster what
you could do with an extra thousand two
thousand bucks a month in income and I
hope that gives you the hope and
motivation that you need to stay the
course and I can't wait for you guys to
come into your debt-free screen and tell
us how it all went sooner rather than
later that puts this hour of the Ramsay
show in the books until next time spend
wisely save intentionally and give
generously
foreign
hey George camel here if you love the
show and you want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we've got a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you helpful
articles and tips on following the
Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
the newsletter again that's
ramseysolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter foreign
[Music]